boa tarde eu queria convidar vocês a
largarem esses cacarecos que a gente tem
na mão um celular bloquinho que ganhou
do ted bolsa dá uma aliviada e nessas
coisas
convidar vocês também para fechar os
olhos um pouquinho
será que a gente consegue sentir esse
espaço sem o sentido da visão quanto tem
à frente de você o que é possível
perceber a partir de suas costas
qual a distância do topo da sua cabeça
até o teto
você consegue expandir todo seu corpo
nessas direções sem fazer nada com isso
vou convidar vocês de novo a abrirem os
olhos e apenas a perceber os materiais
deste espaço
como é a parede que está atrás de mim
o piso dessa sala o teto de concreto a
cadeira de tecido o que é o que é
possível sentir com esses materiais como
eles interferem no seu corpo
também quero que a gente perceba que
este espaço tem uma hierarquia bem clara
vocês estão de costas uns para os outros
e de frente principal aqui então o
arranjo espacial a um arranjo especial e
ele toca o seu corpo o que é possível
pensar desde aí o que é possível pensar
nesse auditório nos corredores da uerj
nas suas rampas nas suas salas de aula
eu pergunto isso porque o espaço tem um
poder
ele atua diretamente nos nossos corpos
ele interfere no como as coisas
acontecem e ajuda a ser o que somos ea
fazer o que fazemos e é por esse poder
por esse poder de atuar no como as
coisas acontecem que ele pode tanto
ajudar a construir um mundo que nos
aprisiona ou ajudar a construir um mundo
que sonhamos habitar
eu faço parte de um coletivo a antram
disciplinar ea gente vem estudando já
faz um tempo como construir espaços que
seja exatamente esse mundo que queremos
adaptar já que vamos construir já que
vamos gastar toda essa energia que é uma
construção e reformar uma casa construir
uma escola uma praça uma cidade
por que não fazer isso para fazer com
que nós sejamos mais fortes mais alegres
mais intuitivos já que vamos gastar essa
energia que gastemos ela ao nosso favor
e nas nossas pesquisas
a gente achou uma coisa muito bacana que
foi essa questão que a gente pegou lá da
análise institucional que foi a passagem
do pedido para a demanda
eu vou contar para vocês o que é isso
a partir de dois exemplos educacionais
já que a gente veio aqui hoje para
debater a uerj que a universidade é um
espaço de educação
o primeiro exemplo eu quero trazer para
vocês é de um arquiteto egípcio chamado
ração fat que atuam na primeira metade
do século passado ele teve uma
oportunidade que foi construir uma
cidade inteira chamada nova urna
dentre os inúmeros projetos que ele fez
eu vou querer falar do projeto da escola
quando ele foi fazer esse projeto
ele se colocou a seguinte questão tende
a abordar o projeto de uma escola da
mesma maneira como aborda o projeto de
uma igreja ou de uma mesquita pois trata
se do mesmo tipo de edifício na escola
são os espíritos das crianças que vão se
desenvolver ea construção deve convidá
los a se expandir e não apertar los como
um sapato chinês
ele simplesmente para antes de construir
antes de a reproduzir o modelo de escola
que nós conhecemos ele parece pergunta
com que parece uma escola que pratica
nós fazemos uma escola e ele percebe que
a gente constrói as nossas escolas na
maior parte das vezes como fábricas como
prisões e não comuns como edifícios
capazes de nos inspirar de expandir o
nosso corpo o nosso espírito e isso
parece uma coisa um pouco etérea se
tornou um problema prático arquitetural
muito claro quando ele foi construir a
sala de aula ele pensou então na
iluminação dessa sala de aula não só de
uma maneira técnica né quanto de luz tem
em cima da mesa que vai que eu vou
conseguir ler e eu consegui escrever que
não vai estragar a máquina divisão né
no meu olho mas é muito mais do que isso
a luz se tornou expressiva se criou uma
atmosfera se criou uma proporção se
criou um ativo logo ao lado da janela
para absorver o excesso de luminosidade
do deserto e deixar entrar na sala só o
adequado para assim conseguir fazer com
que o espaço seja um inspirador seja um
estimulante para pensarmos
para expandirmos para criarmos kim ki o
que for o conhecimento a nós mesmos as
coisas que vamos fazer
então não só o espaço tenha um poder
sobre os nossos corpos
como ainda nós podemos construir um
espaço que nos ajude a pensar que nos
ajude a criar o segundo exemplo que eu
quero trazer para vocês é de uma
arquiteta mark teto e ítalo brasileira
chamada lina bo bardi que deixou um
legado imenso arquitetura brasileira
lina bo bardi na década de 50
recebe um convite recebe um pedido que
foi o pedido de criar o museu de arte
moderna da bahia e logo depois ela
recebe o pedido de recuperar esse
conjunto de edifícios históricos
lá em salvador em 1963 inaugura o
conjunto arquitetônico do solar do unhão
e ele inaugura não com um programa o
museu de arte moderna mas com três
programas inaugura um museu de arte
moderna
na verdade ele se transfere de um outro
lugar inauguro map
o museu de arte popular que tem um
centro de documentação popular e um
centro de estudos técnicos do nordeste e
estava para inaugurar a escola de
desenho industrial
tudo no mesmo conjunto arquitetônico mas
então vocês vão me perguntar ea zona mas
o que aconteceu de um programa foi para
3 o que aconteceu nessa passagem do
pedido para a demanda antes da
construção
eu vou dizer pra vocês que naquela época
salvador era especial ainda é mas era
muito especial porque na universidade
federal da bahia
havia um reitor chamado professor edgar
santos que queria fazer da bahia um
brilho
queria que a bahia voltasse a brilhar no
cenário nacional e no cenário
internacional
esse reitor chamou diversos artistas
internacionais dentre eles nina abobados
para fazer um verdadeiro movimento
cultural e transformar a bahia numa baía
moderna
para vocês terem uma idéia da
importância desse movimento caetano
veloso gilberto gil
glauber rocha betânia todos eles eram
alunos da ufa nesse momento e todos eles
dizem que esse movimento foi crucial
para suas carreiras do bard então não
faz um museu só para guardar obras e
fazer exposições mas faz um museu capaz
de criar um movimento cultural de uma
baía moderna mas ela era muito ousada
ela ainda queria muito mais
ela queria que esse conjunto de
edifícios não tão não tão grandes em tão
singelos mas que eles fossem também
capazes de ajudar a criar um brasil
moderno de ajudar a criar um brasil
moderno e autônomo
mas o que é isso
criar um brasil moderno e autônomo
lina bo bardi era muito próxima nessa
época de darcy ribeiro que como vocês
sabem pedir uma pesquisa antropológica
muito grande de grande importância sobre
o povo brasileiro onde ele publicou esse
livro que tem esse nome o povo
brasileiro e há também uma série de
vídeos no youtube sobre esse mesmo
trabalho sobre esse mesmo nome muito
bonito é muito bonito ver os vídeos
quero falando da potência que somos da
força cultural expressiva que somos lina
roubar de dizia não é qualquer lugar não
é qualquer lugar que tenha uma cultura
forte como essa não é qualquer lugar que
é herdeiro directo de grande sedimenta
ções havia então naquela época naquele
com esse conjunto de intelectuais
artistas estudantes reitores arquitetos
e muito mais
uma vontade de olhar para nós mesmos e
descobrir a nossa potência
lina dizia o balanço da civilização
brasileira popular é necessário mesmo se
pobre à luz da alta cultura este balanço
não é o balanço do folclore sempre
paternalista mente amparado pela cultura
elevada é o balanço visto do outro lado
o balanço participante é o aleijadinho e
à cultura brasileira antes da missão
francesa é o nordestino do cori das
latas vazias
é o habitante das vilas é o negro é o
índio é uma massa que inventa que traz
uma contribuição de gesta seca e dura de
gerir e ela não só queria tudo isso ela
vai fazer o que ela propõe essa é a
escada do casarão principal do solar do
unhão
o encaixe desse degrau é o mesmo encaixe
do carro de boi
essa escada é ao mesmo tempo arrojada
moderna e nordestina sertaneja seca
necessária
é por essas escadas que nós circular
íamos é por essas escadas que o brasil
poderia se afirmar moderno não só escada
os objetos com que a gente comia roupa
com que a gente tivesse a praça que a
gente apita a escola que a gente estuda
tudo isso poderia ser ao mesmo tempo
moderno ao mesmo tempo próprio ao mesmo
tempo vindo da força da cultura popular
brasileira que não é pouca coisa
eles conseguem então fazer nesse momento
muita coisa esse projeto ele acabou com
a ditadura
infelizmente mas eles conseguiram nesse
tempo muita coisa eles conseguiram em
primeiro lugar e eu acho que tem muito a
ver conosco hoje é fazer uma
universidade viva fazer uma universidade
onde a gente cria as coisas possa criar
possa inventar artistas que não existiam
grandes artistas rocinha possa fazer da
universidade um lugar pulsantes que não
só criaria ela mesma mas criaria
salvador criaria bahia queria o brasil
mundo moderno e ao mesmo tempo singular
universal e singular ao mesmo tempo né
ea segunda coisa que esse exemplo nos
mostra é que não só o espaço atuam no
nosso corpo
não só ele pode ser feito para que
possamos pensar em si e expandir mas ele
pode ainda ser um meio para alcançar
certos resultados coletivos
ele pode tá no coração de um
agenciamento ainda maior que possa
transformar ainda mais coisas como é
este caso
o que eu quero então dizer pra vocês que
esses dois exemplos maravilhosos é que a
arquitetura é que o espaço construído
não só nos abrigar da chuva do vento do
sol nem só também organiza o nosso
cotidiano aqui a gente lava louça que
agente donna que a gente estuda mas é
uma grande oportunidade
é uma grande oportunidade
idade para nós mesmos pensar que modo
nós habitamos a terra
de que modo nós habitamos a terra e nós
fazemos uma passagem para o mundo que
queremos habilitar a construir essa
passagem
essa pergunta ela está sempre em
qualquer espaço a gente pode fingir que
ela não existe
ou a gente pode se apropriar dela o
problema é que quando a gente finge que
ela não existe o que a gente faz a gente
reproduz os modelos acaba com as
diferenças e acaba nos enfraquecendo com
isso mas se a gente assumir essas
perguntas pra gente se a gente faz delas
o nosso caminho
aí pode ser diferente aí ao invés de ele
eliminar a diferença nós criaremos
diferenças mas não só confirmaremos a
diferença que somos criaremos ainda
outras ainda maiores coisas que não
imaginamos que podemos ser
aí sim os territórios podem servir para
potencializar a vida para potencializar
a nossa vida e eu vou convidar vocês de
novo a fecharem um pouquinho os olhos ea
deixar reverbera nos seus corpos
tudo isso fazer com que a bahia da
década de 50
nossa tá aqui possa estar em ocupando a
uerj
agora de maneira contemporânea agora no
rio de janeiro e eu devolvo a pergunta
tão bonita de se ted é o que nos faz
universidade
eu devolvo a ampliando o que nos faz
universidade no rio que queremos habitar
o que nos faz universidade no rio de
janeiro que sonhamos e queremos
construir e deixa essa utopia
essa beleza entrar aqui nessa
universidade percorresse auditório
percorrer as rampas da uerj a sua sala
de aula a cantina que você vai
como ela seria deixa isso se transformar
a partir de um processo a partir do
desejo de querer construir ainda mais
com esse espaço a gente pode construir
isso e ainda mais que lina bo bardi de
ração fat
nós podemos hoje construir isso de modo
participativo colaborativo ou com cody
zaine como as pessoas gostam de dizer é
só nós tocarmos e quer e vamos nessa
juntos certo
obrigado
[Aplausos]